Wendy we had this comment come in a
couple days ago on YouTube and the
viewer asked what should writers be
concerned with when revising their
second or third draft of something a
really good question because I know like
we all talked about a first draft but
invariably the biggest part of writing
your script is the rewrite in the
rewrite and the rewrite I think the
biggest danger is well put it this way
the purpose and the benefit is that it's
going to get clearer and crisper and
better and tighter so the danger is when
you lose sight of what your core vision
is now there are two ways this could
happen first if you've never haven't had
a strong core vision to begin with then
each draft the goal should be to refine
what that is and maybe the writer needs
to do an outline first and be really
clear and I do recommend I think Blake
Snyder has a very effective beat sheet
that's a useful tool and again I tell
writers that use it as a general guide
and a general map but don't feel that
you have to adhere to like oh I've got
to insert this moment at exactly this
page or try to contrive things you must
be organic to your follow your own
organic process the another thing just
with like about rules and following
formulas I'd like to use as an example
when you see a great prima ballerina
like I saw many years ago
Makarova who was one of the preeminent
ballerinas when I was growing up and she
you know that she practiced her bars and
she knew her craft but when she got on
stage you then abandon it it becomes
second nature that you should know your
craft but that you can be free enough to
let the muse flow through you if you're
so manufactured where you're trying to
hit every plot point and you're writing
from
that place you're not going to have the
magic and the kind of flow that a writer
needs to have to really create magical
characters and dialogue and story so but
it's helpful to have this map so this is
for a writer who might not have core
vision to begin with for most writers
they do have a core vision of their
piece and the danger becomes when you
lose your Center and you start listening
to you're like a weed in the wind that
you keep swaying so this person said I
should do this so I'm going to do that
this person said you keep going just in
too many different directions it is an
art to be able arter a balance to be
able to take advice feedback suggestions
from other people let it go through a
sieve earth-like filter and something
that occurs to me is to maybe approach
the advice the way they make
recommendations with meditation when
you're when thoughts come to you it's
not that you're so rigid about I can't
think any thoughts I can't think any
thoughts so the same way you're not
being richer than that I'm not going to
take anyone suggestions and you're not
saying I'm gonna take everyone's
suggestions you okay let's see this was
a good idea I'm gonna let that percolate
this idea I don't think it really fits
in with the vision so I'm gonna put that
one aside
I'll reexamine it just in case there's
something there I need to look at and
there are others that you may go oh this
person they don't get it at all
maybe I'm doing something that's not
making it clear enough but I don't I
don't think they're the right person to
give me advice for this you cannot a you
can't be a pleaser where you're trying
to please everybody but generally
speaking if there is valuable feedback
then to take it in and put it through
your own filter and prod
Sisson see how you can address so the
biggest danger is losing sense of self
and trying to please everybody and then
you wind up with mush and that's nothing
it's neither here and are there there's
no vision so can we just define
coalition here would be a really good
example I had a client who had a
one-hour drama that was inspired by his
life experiences and he had a really
really interesting story based on his
profession and he sent me the draft he
had told me the log line and what he had
done and then I read the draft and I was
like this doesn't sound at all like your
story and he had changed the protagonist
to a woman which can be fine but there
were it felt so manufactured and
contrived and so I just said a very
innocent question I said I'm really
curious because what you would pitch to
me based on your life experience was so
fascinating and riveting and I felt like
and that's what really interested me
about the idea for this pilot and I
didn't see what I know of you I didn't
see any of you in this pilot whether it
was a male or female character and he
told me that he had taken a number of
writing the workshops were or script
coverage services and certainly there
are good ones out there but one they
said you should change it to a female
you should make the protagonist a woman
not a man someone else said oh you
should give her this backstory and you
should give her such and such kind of
relationship with her mother and with an
abusive boyfriend and it became so far
removed from what I thought was really
the core vision or essence of the story
that he wanted to tell and he let go of
that and came up with something that and
I he said I didn't even want to write
this but I thought I should you know
that these were people who were telling
me that I that I should so that's what I
think you need to stick with your core
vision that would be an example it's a
great place to start on we talked about
being able to take constructive
criticism and not being defensive and
being open to the notes what if people
are giving you super nice feedback about
things and it feels disingenuous and
you're not sure is this just a person
that's trying to please me mm-hmm it
doesn't even have to be a family member
or friend and how do we see through that
good question I think one is to say when
you're seeking constructive criticism
because it is coming from a I mean I
this is how I'd like to give notes and
if I'm asking someone to evaluate
something for me I may say I need you to
be gentle
this is my style I don't respond well to
someone who's going to shred everything
but I do want honest feedback so if
someone a lot of writers will say to me
and I usually say before I do consulting
I say I want to make sure that you want
honest feedback certainly everyone has
an opinion what you will get from me is
an informed opinion being that I am I do
feel it as one of my strengths as we get
older I think we come to know what some
of our strengths are my affinity for
literature from a young age to you know
working in the business and working for
a long time with writers and loving the
process and that when you as a writer
when you ask an opinion that you a lot
of regulars will say to me I want an
honest I will don't be afraid you can be
brutal etc it's not my desire or style
to be brutal because I don't like my
teachers I did not feel that's
constructive but I do feel that I also
say to my clients I'm not doing you a
favor
if I don't provide an honest assessment
based on my experiences in the business
stun my knowledge of how other industry
executives respond to material it's not
the only opinion certainly but it will
be an informed opinion so I think that
when writers are asking for a feedback
that they if someone's really like oh I
loved everything I loved everything that
they you say I don't want you to just
say this to be nice if you have
something that you think is constructive
and I can improve I would really
appreciate that I would really value
that
you